.
Wenn Dunkelheit und Ruhe
einkehren ...
... und dem ganzen Land eine ge-
heimnisvolle Schönheit verleihen ...
... wenn die einen bereits schlafen,
erzählen die anderen
ihre Geschichten.
Geschichten, einzigartig und
verborgen, kommen zum Vorschein.
Auf unserer Reise von der Dämmerung
bis zum Morgengrauen
durch eine herbstliche Nacht
in der Schweiz.
MIT TELETEXT-UNTERTITELUNG
Ein sonniger Tag geht zu Ende.
* Kuhglocken, Grillenzirpen *
Es ist Zeit, sich einen Platz
zum Schlafen zu suchen.
Hier ist der Grenzstein.
Das ist St. Gallen.
Das ist Thurgau.
David Schuler hilft eigentlich
seinem Vater auf dem Bio-Hof,
doch heute Nacht ist er
Butler seines Null-Sterne-Hotels.
(Frau) Wow. Das ist unser Bett?
Ja, jetzt noch zugedeckt
wegen des Wetters.
Aber das System ist sehr einfach.
Einfach rundherum
den Gummi rausnehmen.
Ein Bett unter dem Sternenhimmel
mit Room-Service.
Alles für knapp 300 Fr.,
inklusive Frühstück am Bett.
Idee und Konzept
stammen vom Künstlerduo Riklin.
Und dann hier einfach kurbeln.
Falls es regnet, wäre ich froh,
wenn ihr es
an beiden Ecken herauszieht
und wieder mit den Gummis festmacht.
Oh, wow, so schön.
Für die Suiten ohne Dach und Wände
ist exakt vorgegeben,
wie das Bett auszusehen hat
und wie es ausgerichtet sein muss.
Falls ihr mitten in der Nacht
noch eine Flasche Wein wollt
oder eine Gutenachtgeschichte
oder so, einfach anrufen.
Ich bin 24 Std. euer Butler.
Renata und Silvius Breitenfeld
haben heute Nacht
das Rundum-Sorglos-Paket gebucht.
Mich reizen die Sterne,
und ich hoffe,
wenn das Feuer aus ist,
werden richtig viele zu sehen sein.
Ja, das gibt eine gute Glut.
Die Kleiderordnung für den Butler
ist streng.
Weisses Hemd, weisse Handschuhe,
schwarze Fliege.
Unterhalb des Gürtels
ist die Kleiderwahl jedoch frei.
Das Outfit gehört einfach
zu dem Hotelservice, den wir bieten.
Auch wenn das Hotel auf dem Land
ist, auf einem Bauernhof.
Es ist wie ein Kostüm für mich.
Ich sage immer als Witz,
das ist mein Clownkostüm.
Das ziehe ich an
und bediene so die Gäste.
Aber praktisch ist es nicht.
Auf dem Bauernhof
trägt niemand weisse Handschuhe,
eine Fliege,
und das weisse Hemd
wird schnell dreckig.
Die Handschuhe
muss ich jeden Tag waschen.
Die Betten werden gut gebucht,
Gäste kommen aus der ganzen Welt.
Hier habt ihr noch ein Wasser.
Wenn man Kind ist, möchte man gerne
unter den Sternen schlafen.
Das war mein Traum als Kind.
Einfach schlafen,
dann die Augen öffnen
und die Sterne sehen.
Sollte es heute Nacht doch regnen,
können die Gäste
in einen sog. Back-up-Room
ins Bauernhaus flüchten.
Dort ist auch eine Toilette.
Die meisten schlafen nicht gut, weil
sie mehrmals in der Nacht aufwachen,
wegen des Windes,
der Kuhglocken usw.
Aber es ist einfach ein Erlebnis.
* Sanfte Musik *
Der König der Ostschweiz:
der Säntis.
Hier grenzen drei Kantone aneinander,
die beiden Appenzell
und der Kanton St. Gallen.
Auf 2'500 m Höhe
bereits der erste Schnee.
Das Berggasthaus Alter Säntis
wird bald schliessen.
Knapp 20 km nördlich: St. Gallen.
Die OLMA findet dieses Jahr
wegen Corona sehr reduziert statt.
Nur 150 Aussteller sind zugelassen,
aber auf eine Mini-Chilbi
wollte man trotzdem nicht verzichten.
Die Kirche St. Laurenzen -
lange der politische und
gesellschaftliche Mittelpunkt
der Stadtrepublik
und mit der Reformation
Zentrum der Reformationsbewegung.
Sie liegt keine 100 Schritte entfernt
vom Zentrum des Fürstbistums
und vom Kloster.
Heute gehört der gesamte Stiftsbezirk
zum Weltkulturerbe der UNESCO.
Nur 11 km östlich am Bodensee:
Rorschach.
* Sanfte Musik *
Etwa ein Drittel des Sees
gehört zur Schweiz.
Arbon: Die kleine Halbinsel
war schon in der Steinzeit besiedelt.
Pfahlbauten belegen das.
Der Romanshorner Hafen
ist der grösste am Bodensee
und Heimathafen der Bodenseefähre.
Von hier aus überquert die Fähre
den See an seiner breitesten Stelle.
Der Bodensee
hat durchaus seine Tücken.
See-Nebel fordert immer wieder Opfer:
Über 300 Wracks liegen auf dem Grund.
* Sanfte, tragende Musik *
Der Rheinfall bei Schaffhausen.
Hier stürzen pro Sekunde
je nach Jahreszeit
500'000 l Wasser
die 23 m hohen Felsen hinunter.
Der Sage nach
sieht man in mondhellen Nächten
oft ein nebelhaftes Schifflein
mit einem Fährmann
zwischen dem Doppelriff
des Rheinfalls hinabgleiten
und in den milchweissen,
überschäumenden Fluten verschwinden.
Nur gut 20 km südlich:
der Flughafen Zürich.
Kurz vor 23 Uhr
ist die letzte Maschine gelandet.
Im Kontrollfahrzeug Gusti 1
beginnt Rolf Wallner seine Schicht.
Bei ihm laufen alle Fäden
der Pistenkontrolle zusammen.
Eugen 11, du kannst raus.
* Klingeln *
Airport Authority, Wallner.
Sind die Regeln,
die Vorgaben eingehalten?
Stehen Sachen herum,
die weggeblasen werden könnten?
Das müssen wir wissen,
das müssen wir uns anschauen.
Und darum rufen sie uns an,
Tag und Nacht.
Der Nachtwächter des Flughafens
verantwortet
den kompletten Aussenbereich.
Insbesondere
die Start- und Landebahnen.
Mit Trockeneis
reinigen die Elektriker
Lorenzo Gomez und Michael Walser
die Leuchtfeuer der Piste 16.
Hey, Lorenzo.
- Hallo, Rolf.
Wir machen die Piste fertig,
danach können wir
mit der Messung anfangen.
Okay.
Tipptopp. Wir geben dir Bescheid,
sobald wir so weit sind.
Danke.
- Super.
Ciao, Rolf.
Die Lichtmessung ist wichtig.
Defekte Lampen
gefährden den Flugbetrieb.
(Funk)
Ich schalte euch die 16 auf 100 %.
Super. Vielen Dank.
Jetzt lassen sich
die einzelnen Lampen
mit blossem Auge
nicht mehr unterscheiden.
Dafür braucht es einen Filter.
Die Leuchtfeuer der grössten Piste
des Zürcher Flughafens
sind für die Piloten bei klarer Sicht
schon von Deutschland aus zu sehen -
30 km vor der Landung.
Mehr links.
Perfekt, super. So passt es.
Kommt jemand von rechts?
Ist alles frei.
Pistenkreuzung ist gut.
Mit diesem Augenschutz sehe ich nur
die einzelnen Lichtpunkte am Boden
und vielleicht
knapp 10 m von der Piste.
Ich kann nicht genau bestimmen,
ob es die Pistenbefeuerung
oder ein anderes Fahrzeug ist
Noch 100 m.
Michi als Beifahrer
hat viel bessere Sicht
und kann mich rechtzeitig warnen.
30.
20.
10.
Und ...
... stopp!
Defekte oder lichtschwache Lampen
werden sofort ausgewechselt.
Ob Starkstrom, mittlere Spannungen
oder Schwachstrom,
die beiden Elektriker
haben jede Nacht zu tun.
Den Flughafen erlebt man nie
so ruhig wie in der Nacht.
Wir sind nur wenige Personen,
die das hier erleben dürfen.
Es ist etwas Besonderes, wenn man
sich auf der Piste bewegen darf.
Geschafft.
Zeit für die finale Kontrollfahrt.
Turm, Gusti 1, guten Morgen.
Rollweg Echo 9.
Kann ich auf Piste 16?
Gusti 1, Turm, du kannst
von Rollweg Echo 9 auf Piste 16.
Turm, Gusti 1 geht
Rolf Wallner hat das letzte Wort.
Nur er darf die Startbahn freigeben.
Ich schaue, ob alles sauber ist,
ob alle Lampen leuchten.
Wenn es Bauarbeiten gab,
schaue ich, ob Dreck rumliegt.
Es lagen schon
Pickel oder Zangen rum.
Die sehe ich und nehme sie weg.
Und wenn alles gut ist,
bin ich der Letzte auf der Piste,
bevor der Flugbetrieb losgeht.
Überspitzt gesagt:
Ich rette jeden Tag
Tausenden von Menschen das Leben,
wenn ich meinen Job richtig mache.
Wie gesagt,
das ist überspitzt gesagt.
Turm,
Gusti 1 ist weg vom Pistensystem.
Rollweg Echo 6 alles gut.
Danke für die Zusammenarbeit.
Schlaf gut, schönen Tag.
In wenigen Stunden,
pünktlich um 6 Uhr,
wird die erste Maschine
Zürich in Richtung Athen verlassen.
Nur einen Katzensprung
vom Flughafen entfernt:
die kleine Weltstadt
und das Finanzzentrum Zürich.
Mitten im Stadtzentrum
der Hauptbahnhof.
Das Schweizer ÖV-Netz
ist eins der dichtesten der Welt.
Gleise prägen das gesamte Stadtbild.
Die meisten Bahnlinien
führen direkt am Toni-Areal vorbei.
Die ehemalige Milchfabrik beherbergt
heute die Hochschule der Künste.
* Sanfte Musik *
Haltestelle für viele S-Bahnen
aus der Agglomeration:
der Bahnhof Zürich Hardbrücke.
Im Sportzentrum Heuried
kündigt sich mitten im Herbst
bereits der Winter an.
Limmatquai, Nieder- und Oberdorf.
Fraumünster,
St. Peterskirche und Grossmünster,
die drei grossen Kirchen der Stadt.
Weit über die Landesgrenzen hinaus
bekannt:
die Eidgenössische
Technische Hochschule ETH.
Die Liste der Absolventen
und Lehrenden,
insbesondere
in der Fachrichtung Physik,
liest sich wie ein Who's who
der Nobelpreisträger.
* Lockere, elektronische Musik *
Auf dem Platz vor der Oper
geniessen die Menschen
die letzten warmen Abende.
Weiter seeaufwärts:
die geordnete Welt des
Schweizer Architekten Le Corbusier.
Die Fahrt vom Zürcher Hauptbahnhof
nach Uster dauert nur 14 Min.
Durch den Bau von Kreiseln
hat die Stadt mittlerweile
alle Verkehrsampeln bis auf eine
abgeschafft.
* Muhen *
Heute Nacht ist die Region
Schauplatz von Filmarbeiten.
Auf einem Bauernhof wird
die neue TV-Serie "Neumatt" gedreht.
Achtung, wir drehen.
Ton ab.
And action.
In der weiblichen Hauptrolle:
das Schweizer Schauspieltalent
Sophie Hutter.
Die Atmosphäre ist anders,
die Konzentration ist anders.
Es gibt so wenig Ablenkung
von Licht und Verkehr oder so.
Es ist so ...
Es zieht sich alles zusammen.
Also ...
Man könnte es auch als ...
... zauberhaft beschreiben.
Die Konzentration, die Energie halten
und jederzeit abrufen können,
das zeichnet Schauspieler aus.
Dreharbeiten
heissen aber v.a. auch warten.
Viel und lange warten.
Das ist noch sehr humanes Warten.
Es gibt andere Stillstände,
die anstrengender sind.
Das ist am Tag
eigentlich genauso anstrengend,
auch da wird man sehr müde.
Wir müssen ja häufig wegen dem Licht
sowieso um 6 Uhr aufstehen,
oder im Winter noch früher.
Und dann ist man auch am Tag
einfach kaputt.
Die TV-Serie erzählt die Geschichte
einer Bauernfamilie -
wie die Jungen um den Erhalt
des elterlichen Hofes kämpfen.
Was machst denn du hier?
Hi.
Das ist zu früh.
Gemeinsam mit Regisseurin Sabine Boss
inszeniert Pierre Monnard
das Familiendrama.
Und dann siehst du,
dass dein Bruder
die Verkörperung der Unschuld ist.
Ja.
Und das tut dir gut.
- Das stimmt, ja.
Man ist mehr bei sich,
und das tut den Figuren auch gut.
Schauspielerei ist ja auch,
aus der eigenen Haut,
aus meiner Normalität als Sophie
rauszugehen.
Und manchmal
ist das nachts einfacher.
Sechs Szenen stehen auf dem Plan.
Dafür sind 38 Personen
seit 18 Uhr auf dem Set.
Kameramann Pietro Zuercher
mag Nachtdrehs.
Es stehen noch weitere Nachtdrehs an.
Verzögert wegen Corona
wird erst im Winter abgedreht sein.
Cut. Wunderbar. Danke, Jérôme.
Kurz vor 2 Uhr ist heute Drehschluss.
Westwärts über den Zürichsee
nach Horgen.
Die Fähre Meilen-Horgen befördert
mehr als 2 Mio. Pendler jährlich
und verkehrt in den Stosszeiten
im 6-Min.-Takt.
Gottfried Keller
setzte im Herbst 1874
Horgen ein literarisches Denkmal.
Seine Novelle "Das verlorene Lachen"
spielt in einem Haus
an einem nicht benannten See,
und doch weiss man sofort,
dass es sich um eine der grossen
Seidenfabrikanten-Villen handelt.
Weiter westlich die Stadt Zug.
Dank seiner
wirtschaftsfreundlichen Steuerpolitik
heute der wohlhabendste Kanton
der Schweiz.
* Lockere Musik *
Fast 35'000 Firmen
haben ihren Sitz hier.
Eine Grosszahl
von internationalen Pharmaunternehmen
unterhält Niederlassungen
und Forschungseinrichtungen.
Neben Industrie und Handel
spielt aber auch
die Landwirtschaft eine Rolle.
Bis spät in die Nacht wird die
letzte Ernte des Jahres eingefahren.
Sempach im Kanton Luzern.
Insektenforscherin Eva Knop
ist auf der Pirsch.
Wenn man nachts arbeitet, darf man
keinen Ekel vor Insekten haben,
weil man tatsächlich weniger sieht.
Aber wir möchten natürlich
mit möglichst wenig Licht arbeiten.
Man schätzt, dass über die Hälfte
aller Tiere, die es gibt,
nachtaktiv sind.
Gleichzeitig weiss man fast nichts
darüber, was nachts passiert.
V.a. was kleine wirbellose Tiere
betrifft.
Willst du die Grossen rausnehmen?
Neben dem Netz nutzt die Entomologin
spezielle Lichtfallen,
um die wirbellosen Tiere anzulocken.
Heute Nacht hilft ihr
die Studentin Majken Grimm.
Nehmen wir noch diese Fliege?
Dann haben wir alle.
Ja, und den Rest
kriegen wir beim Leeren.
Es ist sehr wichtig,
dass wir das System nicht stören.
Die meisten Insekten,
die nachts aktiv sind,
reagieren extrem schnell auf Licht.
Es dauert dann relativ lange,
bis sie sich
von diesem Lichtschock erholen.
Es gibt Schätzungen von etwa 1 Std.
Insgesamt gibt es über 20'000
Insektenarten in der Schweiz.
Etwa die Hälfte von ihnen
ist nachtaktiv.
Demgegenüber stehen
gerade mal 100 Säugetierarten.
Trotzdem bedauern
die Wissenschaftlerinnen
jedes Tier,
das für ihre Forschung sterben muss.
Spannend.
Es gab richtig viele.
Hummeln, Nachtfalter.
Wespe. Fliege.
Eeine tote Hummel in der Falle
ist nicht schön.
Aber es ist leider
bei Insekten nicht möglich,
sie anders zu bestimmen.
Man muss sie
in den meisten Fällen umbringen
und dann genau anschauen.
Dank Feldforschung
konnten Eva und ihr Team nachweisen,
dass Insekten nachts
künstlich beleuchtete Blüten meiden
und nicht befruchten.
Die Folgen sind geringere Ernten.
Einerseits ist die Atmosphäre
nachts ganz anders als tagsüber.
Es ist eine unentdeckte Welt, oder
zum grossen Teil unentdeckte Welt.
Das gibt es nicht mehr so oft
in der Ökologie:
Gebiete,
die noch völlig unerforscht sind
und diesen Zauber haben,
dass man nicht wirklich weiss,
was dort läuft.
Du siehst hier das Radargerät.
Ornithologe Felix Liechti.
Er setzt modernste Technik ein:
ein Radargerät.
Damit beobachtet er das
nächtliche Zugverhalten von Vögeln
und anderen Tieren.
Dies im Auftrag der Universität Bern
und der Vogelwarte Sempach.
Sind das alles Insekten?
Du kannst da unten
die roten Kreuze sehen.
Das sind alles Insekten.
Das ist der Verlauf des Abends
vom Radar aus gesehen,
wenn die Insekten kommen.
Das ist vor der Dämmerung.
Es gibt noch fast keine Insekten.
Das ist eine
relativ durchschnittliche Nacht.
Hier ist eine andere Nacht.
Da sind jetzt ganz viele Insekten.
Fast so viele wie am Tag.
Wohin und warum
bewegen sich Insekten nachts?
Wie beeinflusst Licht
diese Bewegungen?
Diese Fragen wollen die Forscher
mithilfe der Radaraufnahmen
beantworten.
Als wir es noch manuell machten,
konzentrierten wir uns auf die Vögel
und beachteten die Millionen
von Echos der Insekten nicht.
Doch mit der automatischen Aus-
wertung hat man es sofort zur Hand.
Man kann sehr gute Auswertungen
machen und damit arbeiten.
Und es ist
für einen Ornithologen faszinierend,
das Vogelfutter zu untersuchen.
Wie die Insekten das Licht,
so umkreisen die Autos
die Autobahnkreuze
und Auffahrten des Mittellandes.
Mitten im Aargau
über der Ebene und der A1:
das Schloss Lenzburg,
eine der ältesten Höhenburgen.
* Sanfte Musik *
Staufer, Kyburger und Habsburger
lebten darin.
Und während der beiden Kappelerkriege
vor 500 Jahren
diente es den Reformierten
als Operationsbasis.
Mehr einer
nach innen gerichteten Festung
gleicht die Strafanstalt Lenzburg.
In der geschlossenen Abteilung sind
ausschliesslich Männer inhaftiert.
Richtung Westschweiz.
Die riesige Dampfwolke
des Kernkraftwerks Gösgen
ist auch in der Nacht
von Weitem sichtbar.
Gösgen ist eines von drei
Kernkraftwerken im Schweizer Netz.
Der Druckwasserreaktor erzeugt etwa
ein Drittel des Schweizer Atomstroms.
Ziegen als Wachhunde? Nein.
Sie leiht sich
der Kraftwerksbetreiber
von einem örtlichen Bauern
zur Pflege der Wiesen.
Das Perry-Einkaufscenter in Oftringen
wurde vor Kurzem
für knapp 50 Mio. saniert
und um ein Hotel ergänzt.
Kaum eröffnet musste es wegen Corona
vorübergehend wieder schliessen.
Biel: die Sprachgrenze
zwischen der französischen
und deutschsprachigen Schweiz.
Der auffällige Bau Cité du Temps
verbindet die Firmensitze
von Omega und Swatch
und ist einer der zahllosen Hinweise
auf die Bedeutung von Biel
als Uhrenstadt.
Weiter Richtung Südwesten
wechselt immer wieder die Sprache.
Französisch, Deutsch, Französisch.
Abstecher nach Hindelbank.
Hier befindet sich eines der beiden
Frauengefängnisse der Schweiz.
Die rund 100 Plätze sind von Frauen
aus 25 Nationen belegt.
Die meisten
sitzen wegen Drogendelikten.
* Sanfte Musik *
Die Poyabrücke
ist die neueste Brücke in Fribourg.
Ganz der Brückenbautradition
der Stadt verpflichtet,
ist auch sie eine Hängebrücke.
Noch älter als das Schloss Gruyère
aus dem 13. Jh.
ist der berühmte Käse.
Der wurde erstmals 1115
in einer Urkunde des ersten Grafen
von Greyerz erwähnt.
Am Fusse des Moléson
funkeln sie bereits in der Ferne -
die Lichter des Genfersees.
Im Herbst, wenn die Zugvögel
Richtung Südwesten fliegen,
zieht es den Ornithologen
Lionel Maumary und sein Team
in die Berge bei Montreux.
Mit Netzen wollen sie
die durchreisenden Vögel einfangen.
Heute hilft ihm
Martine Wagen-Jaussy aus dem Jura.
Tu me donnes un sac?
Der Trauerschnäpper
ist bereits der dritte Vogel,
den sie heute Nacht fangen.
Schon früh hat Lionel
seine Liebe zu Vögeln entdeckt.
Als andere Kinder damals
Kröten aufbliesen, sagt er,
habe er als Sechsjähriger
ein Rotkehlchen gezähmt.
Bis heute hat er mehr als
350 Vogelarten untersucht.
Martine hat Lionel auf einer seiner
Vogelkundetouren kennengelernt.
Sie unterstützt ihn ab und zu -
ausser dass sie nie
einen Vogel selber beringen würde.
Je l'ai posé. Et il est parti.
* Sanfte Musik *
Lac Leman, Genfersee.
Weinstöcke, Palmen, Villen
und Weltkonzerne.
Von hier bis Vevey
reicht die Riviera vaudoise,
die Côte d'Azur
der Kantone Wallis und Waadt.
Ein bisschen im Dunkeln versteckt,
direkt am Ufer des Sees,
die Hauptverwaltung von Nestlé.
Mit über 300'000 Mitarbeitenden
auf der Welt
gilt Nestlé
als grösster Nahrungsmittelkonzern.
Gleichzeitig ist es das grösste
Industrieunternehmen der Schweiz.
Über drei Hügel
erstreckt sich Lausanne.
Hier im Stade Olympique
de la Pontaise
wurden noch nie
Olympische Spiele ausgetragen,
dafür regelmässig Spiele
des FC Lausanne-Sport.
"Olympisch" heisst das Stadion,
weil in Lausanne der Sitz des IOK,
des Internationalen
Olympischen Komitees ist.
Wegen Corona bleiben die über 15'000
Sitzplätze seit Juni leer.
Im modernen Quartier
rund um die ETH Lausanne
erobern die Menschen in diesen Zeiten
neue und ungewöhnliche Räume,
um den geschlossenen zu entfliehen.
Dieser Porsche Cayenne
kostet in einfachster Ausführung
über 100'000 Fr.
Dank der Graffiti von Sprayer Baro
ist er ein Unikat.
Und unverkäuflich.
Neben dem Porsche
besitzt Baro auch noch einen
innen und aussen besprayten Bentley.
Heute Nacht führt Baro
eine Auftragsarbeit
in der Lausanner Innenstadt aus.
Sein Sprayerkollege Ludovic Ludo
hilft ihm dabei.
* Der Generator brummt laut. *
Dank der Lärmdämmung
können die beiden Graffiti-Künstler
die ganze Nacht durcharbeiten,
ohne die Nachbarn zu stören.
Seine ersten Sprayversuche
unternahm Baro als Jugendlicher.
Am Anfang hat Baro
nachts Züge besprayt.
Er wurde erwischt
und musste sich in einer Fabrik
das Geld für die hohe Busse
verdienen.
Jetzt kann er vom Sprayen leben.
"Während ihr schlaft" - das ist auch
der Titel seines neuesten Werks.
Inzwischen bekommt er Aufträge
aus dem In- und Ausland.
Ici, dans la couette.
- Oui, oui.
Mais moi, je disais de le faire ...
- Au dessus.
Là, tout petit, le bâton de merde.
Il faut qu'il soit
dans le même style.
* Sanfte Musik *
Von Lausanne bis Genf
sind es nur knapp 70 km.
Die meistbefahrene Bahnstrecke
der Romandie.
Höhere Geschwindigkeit
und schnellerer Taktfahrplan
sollen das Bahnfahren
noch attraktiver machen.
Deshalb wird in dieser Nacht
in Genève-Sécheron,
nördlich des Genfer Hauptbahnhofs,
gearbeitet.
Chelso Pereira ist seit 2014 bei
den CFF als Maitre de voies ferrées.
Die alten Schwellen und Schienen
müssen raus
und der Schotter erneuert werden.
Am Tag
wären diese Arbeiten undenkbar,
denn auf dem Nebengleis
läuft der Zugverkehr weiter.
Knapp drei Wochen
sind für die Arbeiten
an der Bahnhofseinfahrt vorgesehen.
Das bedeutet für die Männer
weiterhin Nachtschichten,
von 20 Uhr abends bis 4 Uhr morgens.
* Sanfte Musik *
Bereits früh im Herbst
ziehen die ersten Nebelschwaden
durch den Waadtländer Jura.
Die meisten Berghütten
und Restaurants
haben bereits geschlossen.
Nur noch wenige Touristen
und Ausflügler
sind in der Abgeschiedenheit
der Jurahöhen unterwegs.
Mit 29 °C Wassertemperatur sprudeln
die schwefelhaltigen Thermalquellen
von Yverdon-les-Bains aus dem Boden.
* Sanfte Musik *
Farbenfroh weist nachts
die Banque Cantonale Neuchâteloise
den Weg zu den Häfen.
Am anderen Ende des Sees
thront das Schloss Neuenburg
gemeinsam mit der Kollegiatskirche
auf einem Felsen über der Stadt.
* Pulsierende Musik *
Wie aus dem Nichts
taucht sie plötzlich auf:
die Raffinerie Cressier
zwischen Neuenburger- und Bielersee.
Sie ist die einzige Erdölraffinerie
der Schweiz
und wird durch eine Pipeline
aus der Nähe von Marseille beliefert.
Cressier produziert etwa ein Viertel
aller Mineralölprodukte des Landes.
Kurz vor Sonnenaufgang, wenn
die Temperaturen am niedrigsten sind,
herrschen für ihr Vorhaben
ideale Bedingungen.
Fabian Jobin und Arthur Gremaud
wollen Rehkitze vor dem Tod
durch Mähmaschinen bewahren.
Salut!
Unterstützt werden die beiden
heute früh von zwei Jägern.
C'est celui que tu as vu,
là au fond?
Ihre Drohne ist mit einer
Wärmebildkamera ausgestattet.
Damit will Fabian
die Tiere aufspüren.
Jäger Zacchari Pasquier
soll sie dann aus dem Feld tragen.
Schon am Vortag waren die Jäger hier
und haben ein paar Kitze entdeckt.
Die wollen sie jetzt finden.
Et puis,
là il va aller jusqu'au bout ...
Vraiment, jusque là au coin.
Eine Fläche so gross
wie eineinhalb Fussballfelder
sucht die Drohne in nur 5 Min. ab.
Die meisten Rehkitze
findet man im Sommer,
doch auch im Herbst entdeckt man
immer wieder einzelne Tiere.
Bei jedem dieser gelben Punkte
könnte es sich um ein Rehkitz handeln
oder um andere Wildtiere
wie Hasen, Vögel oder Wildschweine.
Im vergangenen Jahr
konnte man so 750 Tiere retten.
* Surren der Drohne *
Zur Hochsaison ist das Team sogar
mit vier Jägern unterwegs.
So können sie sich besser
auf dem Gelände verteilen.
Alle schon in Sicherheit.
Die Fläche ist rehfrei
und kann gemäht werden.
Die Nacht neigt sich dem Ende zu.
Ein neuer Tag in der
herbstlichen Schweiz bricht an.
* Beschwingte Musik *
SWISS TXT AG / Access Services
Alexandra Duttweiler - 2020